he spent the past few days representing
one Chancellor in Washington how was the
now he ends the week representing
another one entirely but the fact that
the bank of England Governor is still
there doing his job is a big part of the
short story of the life and death of
what some people called trosonomics
like Ronald Reagan and Margaret Thatcher
Liz trust wanted to turn the economy
around pulling down regulations and
taxes and driving up growth but Prime
Ministers don't just answer to their
party members they also answer to Market
and investors don't like uncosted plans
you can't just sort of magic it up
you've got to really have some reasons
why people are going to believe it
uh and we've still heard absolutely
nothing as for as to why
what does this mean in practice well
this is the yield the interest rate on
long-dated UK government debt it's been
a pretty good barometer of nerves in the
UK recently after the mini budget it
climbed scarily quickly getting so high
that the bank of England had to step in
and buy bonds that brought it down for a
bit but the help was only temporary and
the yield soon climbed again until
rumors emerged of the coming u-turn
foreign
no that might all sound abstract but
these are the charts they're looking at
in Downing Street they sealed
quasi-quartang's fate and forced the
latest U-turn which raises an issue when
campaigning Liz truss said the route to
growth was tax cuts now she's dumped
those cuts what about the growth part
I think reversing the corporate tax
amcats is actually quite disappointing
in a way because those are quite
essential to getting investment into the
country as the Prime Minister said in
terms of a go for growth strategy at
putting corporate tax rates up to 25
isn't particularly good news so we end
where we started can you confirm that
you've spoken
seems to be dead the bank of England and
financial markets are in the driving
seat but the road ahead looks just as
bumpy as the one we've just bounced off
at Conway Sky News